my boy mike tyson yeah talk to him yeah
we're in new york here in new york
mike tyson it really just got out
yeah just got out yeah and and and he
hungry yeah yeah we were like hey man
let's i say we're gonna go to dinner he
just got out i'm still on probation yeah
yeah i'm on probation i just got out of
out of my mess all right i'm still on
probation and we go out and he might
make oh yeah
man listen man get out we're at
club that's amazing man
so michael made you
he said you you i heard about you and
the big toes you were talking about yeah
yeah yeah we know we know the pink toes
it's white women yeah snow bunnies
yeah and we went back to his suite over
he was over a trump tower at this big
sweet man and we took you know
everybody in there
here we go
we all go
again
so we're leaving we're leaving me mike
all our buddies yeah and and sitting
there we're getting in my limo we're
getting my limo we're going back to his
suite yeah
t.o was sitting there
t.o was leaving the club too hey man
you're right you know we're gonna go i
said oh come on man we get your ride
put d.o in the room put the car here we
all go
we get back to the whole suite and we
start you know
see over the wall
[Laughter]
looking around mike's mike tyson look at
the young man because he was just a
young buck yeah look at the young buck
the young buck said oh my god my career
is over with mike tyson and mike
was like
you okay man you need me i get my limo
to send you home
[Laughter]
you can take the limo to go home and
then i you two y'all ride with him
you got a road game tonight
he's a little shy make sure he's okay in
the car
oh my god man yeah we did some he did
some crazy things man oh and then mike
tyson of course after a couple of weeks
we messed around for hours he takes my
limo
so i'm gonna take limo maker right here
i don't know where this joker went man
i'm calling it can you bring back the
damn limo man dude
when that driver got back
[Laughter]
tell mike tyson what
[Laughter]
so ferocious man but i just love the
duke i i read a story recently where uh
i think it was maybe one of his trainers
or something he was saying that he would
sleep with girls before the fight to
take the edge off so he wouldn't kill
the person that he was about to fight
like he was trying to weaken himself
right right so he wouldn't be too
violent hey boy
but the fighters are different though
dawg yeah you know i john joe's a great
friend of mine he's kind of told me some
of his pre-fight stuff man those
fighters are boy they different that's
why i respect the hell out of them i
respect the hell out of man because i'm
talking about what y'all do whatever
y'all got to do yeah get your ass in
there yeah y'all hey
i ain't bothering y'all do what you got
to do